this is a production of Cornell
University
I was asked by Neil to continue this
general topic of work culture and
changing climate genetically semester
and SB to talk about crops especially
apples and grapes that I've worked on
for quite a long time and so I be happy
to do that we'd like to acknowledge our
d gaetano from the Climate Center and
also the comstock as we've worked a lot
together over the last year or so on a
project funded by NYSERDA interview
research and development project to look
at climate effects on various aspects
it's a very broad range of project on
climate effects on New York so I've been
focusing on the apples and grapes and
we'd like to give you a quick overview
of what we think are some of the
important factors that are occurring now
as well as in the future but a lot of
the climate information is from art so I
had to
definitely acknowledge those
contributions there so really some of
the key question is are has our climate
been changing recently already we're
just looking at potential climate change
are we really talking about a
continuation of climate change what
happened some of the effects on apples
and grapes in New York due to climate
change and then what changes are
expected for our climate over the next
15 20 30 40 70 80 years or so and what
I'd like would be some of those effects
obviously there's lots and lots of
things you can talk about that first
list let's just see point out that the
climate is already changing there's
really not too much data about that
especially in the last 40 or 50 years
the annual temperatures across New York
with 105 42 degrees Fahrenheit which is
a major change on climatic scale the
winter temperatures are warmed by nearly
five degrees Fahrenheit so the winters
are attending to warm up more than the
summers which is generally good most of
us we're willing to let them work the
winter to warm up warm and then the data
less spring frost has become earlier
interesting data on that and that there
are two more days per year or 90 degrees
Fahrenheit and corset berries with your
location in the state but there's been
an increase in numbers of very hot days
as well this is a but from our just
showing the the general trend
hundred years of the the top line the
black pair regression lines of the
hundred year trend which is about almost
three degrees warming last hundred years
but he also made a regression from
nineteen seventy or nineteen eighty
eight feet oh sorry nineteen seventy
this tops of two thousand of course
we've met some of the hottest years
since that grassed on so the progression
since the nineteen seventy has been
quite a bit steeper with about four and
a half degree warming over the last
thirty years which is not only a large
amount of warming but it's a large
amount forming over very short for
Jasmine time period and as mentioned the
winters have been formation more than
the summers now this is from the
projects the art work with a song for
the great Ben de street but basically
took his high resolution algorithms to
estimate temperatures between weather
stations to get more high resolution map
of temperatures and we have them go
backwards for about 30 years and
generate these high-resolution estimates
of daily temperatures backwards for
about 30 years so we can summarize them
over a 30-year period which is really
what you need to look at climatic change
rather than just five or ten years what
we can see is even
short period these plots are the average
number of days per year with
temperatures below minus 10 Fahrenheit
that's a threshold value for grapes
especially for great bud kill or
different grapes premium wine grapes so
that's sort of a key temperature before
they get winter hardiness issue for
grapes and so on the on the top left you
can see the fly in which on the left
side of the scale the warmer
temperatures the Reds the oranges
yellows are warmer in the blues and
purples and greens or colder and so the
upper left you can see the during that
nineteen eighty to nineteen ninety
period what the general distribution was
and you can see why they're grapes wine
grapes that are growing are growing in
the finger lakes near the legs a little
bit up assume Valley deseo to Long
Island because those are the warmer spot
but then we just shipped into the last
ten years of the data set that were
generated at the time in the lower right
and you can see by just preparing them
significant changes in the warming of
the winters and the numbers of days with
with these killing
so actually if you look at Pennsylvania
you can see the really dramatic change
so these have been very very strong
changes in just quite a short time
period now some of the implications of
that we look at those episode of an
overview this just Geneva data and in
the pot you can see we planted the
coldest temperature each winter since
nineteen forty eight or so on up to this
year and what you can see is obviously
you're interested in the in the trance
at the bottom because those are the ones
that really cost promise for the the
great wine industry and so I put a barn
on there showing of that minus 10 to
minus 15 or 16 Fahrenheit is the sort of
danger zone where if you're minus 10 or
so that's into the bud kill point you
about that you'll lose some buds but
it's not a commercial real problem you
get below minus 10 and you can really
start having some problem but since we
remove close to the buds from great
minds anyway we can tolerate significant
amount of bud kill but then we certainly
a dynamite routine 16 you're looking at
behind kill so that's sort of your
danger zone and you can see that before
nineteen eighty or so about every 45
years or so there was a significant kill
and that was rather discouraging the
growers but since about nineteen eighty
until we had a couple of cool years they
are over 40 5 but since during that 20
82 years
28 three-year period we didn't have any
dramatic we have a little bit of both
killed but not a significant winter
injury and I think this really allowed
our vanilla winding distribute to
develop dramatically in nineteen eighty
i think we had around 20 or 22 wineries
and now we have think it's about 300 now
in the state and many of them posted
really have been interested in growing
cretan language so i think the winter
warming trends that we've had been
really quite positive for the great wine
industry in to work so as an example of
one of the positives climate change when
you're on the cold side you will see
some positives and then of course
episode winter we can look at the length
of the growing season a similar way of
showing us and it's so it is increasing
it's not quite as dramatic and easy to
see but if you look for the oranges and
reds clearly you're seeing more of those
in the later later years somewhat less
of the blues and greens so season has
been getting getting somewhat longer as
well then the warmth of the growing
season is it really the season to
getting warmer and again comparing the
same way yes it appear
they're getting more of the oranges and
reds coming into New York you can see
the warming going at some valley and the
finger lakes are are getting warmer
again so quite a bit of evidence that it
says we're growing seasons or getting
somewhat longer getting some warmer the
winters are getting and these can have
had some significant tax relief now one
other thing that a lot of times we don't
really talk about is such the co2 money
in the atmosphere obviously is one of
the drivers for climate change in that
it absorbs infrared heat being radiated
from the from the earth and that's why
it's a greenhouse gas so but it also has
direct effect on plants talk about that
a little bit but one of the things that
so it's very striking is the is how
rapidly the carbon dioxide is going up
in the the atmosphere now when I came if
you follow this 320 parts per billion
line over right about just about the
printing it was when I arrived about an
infra gas analyzer as part of my startup
money so I started measuring the co2 in
the air it's 320 parts per million now
it's 380 parts per day
so the 60 part remain change in
atmospheric co2 just since I've been
measuring now the point is that the
atmosphere is changing rapidly not that
I've old yeah I mean I I think some
might think I should be measured of
geologic time but it's just the rapidity
of the change in the sea of two is just
astounding and so just a comparison I
just went back and I circle that that
change that occurred over like 35 years
versus is a one of the changes during
way back when and they estimated of duty
to 50,000 years to have a similar type
of change so the point is it's not only
going up higher than it's ever been but
it's going up fast and it's just not
something that we can ignore but it does
have some that can be some positive
effects of that as well in general you
know go see it's a it's going to be a
good news story yes the big output prova
co2 down and that earlier time thank you
I don't
you gotta know there's a lot of volcanic
activities and a lot of geological stuff
going on so I don't really know all the
reasons for that okay the besides
temperatures the rainfall has been
changing somewhat it actually has a
increasing slightly generally the
increases when you have a warming period
and a cold area like this the increases
in precipitation tend to be in the
spring fall because in March or not
october november when in the past it
might freeze and be quite dry conditions
and some snow if it's warmer and the
lakes stay warmer and you tend to get
more rainfall that period the summers 10
did not change quite as much but overall
there's a little bit of a trend in
precipitation being similar or
increasing subway but the tendency has
been in a couple couple different things
one is it it's tended to be more erratic
rainfall so heavy rainfall is a 2-inch
type of of rain falls occurring and so
if you have the same amount of total
rain but you're getting it and fewer
major heavy
fours then you may be expecting to have
work traps in between if you're getting
st. line rain also if you have a heavy
downpour a lot of time you get a letter
run off so the rain may not be as
effective yes or frequent small amounts
of rain so that's one thing we need to
be aware of for the future is that it's
affected to have that trend continue
more and more also of a snowfall has
declined by susan lunches 20 inches of
some parts of the state I know around
here talking to people that have lived
here all their life they've seen quite
dramatic change drop-offs and you better
snowfall but in some of the lake effect
areas intend to get increased rainfall
because of the lake surface temperatures
warming up and providing a providing
more heat or humidity for about
lake-effect snows so there's a lot of
things going on all of the totals are
really not changing dramatically also
we've boots it seems as though we've
been getting more droughts and this is a
long-term plat more of a meteorological
estimate of drought and this case
anything above the line is a drought in
ink below the line is is a is more of a
wet year and so there was a period in
the 1930s on highest peak I think was 33
and that was an extreme drought
the Dust Bowl that sort of thing those
tended to correlate with warmer
temperatures at that time that I believe
is related to a high solar activity at
that time however the solar activity is
really one of the lows now apparently so
the this plot Holy Ghost about 1997 the
next over the next 13 years we continue
to have significant droughts off and on
but more ready partly than any average
years lately they tended to be cold web
tried so we do expect that we're going
to have continued erratic weather so we
will have droughts we will have floods
so that's something that has been
occurring actually the anomaly really is
the 1970s there were probably any
droughts at all it was a relatively cool
wet wet period throughout that whole
decade okay so what have been some of
these some of the impacts entered a few
but I did list that the premium wine
industry which is based on the coal
tender varieties like coverage amateur
teen I've really been able to expand
greatly a lot of the expansion has been
supported by research on learning how to
how to grow the vines better cold
tolerance and how to prune them or wait
not true but I believe a lot of it's
been allowed to occur because of the
climate change bloom dates are tending
to get earlier show show you that giving
us a lot longer growing seasons and our
fruit crops our crops that are able to
take advantage of that some plants you
plant them 80 to 90 days or whatever
they're done and then if you have a
longer growing season you really don't
take advantage of it our crops make
perennials come out as soon as they can
in the spring and they're not really day
length control so in the fall if you
have a nice log fall they just keep
their ladies and they keep functioning
and really the places that have the
highest yield ones that have a longest
growing seasons because their apples and
grapes are able to account to the length
of the growing season so that's a really
manage of our do the crops and also
apple trees look at dr adam production
of potential yields and they really are
able to take advantage of long growing
seasons such as New Zealand where they
can typically produce almost twice as
much fruit per hectare as we can in New
York and it's not corner so they're able
to do this primarily through the
extended growing season okay so now of
course some of the warmer seasons and
the droughts not only drought a cool
drought doesn't have nearly effect as a
hot trap so when you get
former years and then you get droughts
on top of it the effect is even stronger
so we've had more he was with some
drought symptoms occurring this in the
last 40 or 50 years and and thus the
need for irrigation or growers putting
irrigation in or wishing they had
deviation and but that can be quite good
though for red wine varieties Cabernet
family don't do very well when it's
really moist humid during the whole
season so the drought years or the years
that we get really nice red Cabernet tag
lines and just in China American talk
talk to you all about some reasons for
that so so there are there's a mixture
of things that that are happening
because of that now this look at some
examples here's the data Apple Bloom
these are used from about nineteen sixty
five or so up until the present and you
can see us with any biological response
is a quite variable because they're
responding to the to the climate but
overall there's been a very significant
trend how the brain changes then about
eight days and over that 40-year period
or so it's a quite market increase or
earlier bloom of apples and of course
we're expecting that too
to continue this is the plot from
fredonia where the Concordat bloom dates
were collected from a a one experiment
that doesn't show set up will continue
in Terra Bates continued so these are
actually data from the same exact plants
for 50 years so and you can see the
trend is quite clear not quite as much
by the half days or so over that time
period and I think that's because grapes
bloom about a month later than apples
that is for more into the summer which
hasn't been warming quite as much but
again still a fairly clear trend for
climate based responses now I mentioned
the co2 that is a not only that's to the
climate the heating issue but it's also
used by plants and so we have done some
studies with our canopy balloon chambers
here where we can see or to enrich them
and we've done some co2 response curves
now these are short short term responses
so a lot of a lot of different plants
will show similar type of response many
plants when you're grown at higher co2
levels down regulate because they're
really not able to utilize that extra
carbon and so then they tend to
down-regulate before synthesis so that
they don't really see a dramatic effect
in an hour long run we have not really
been able to
the free our co2 enrichment studies that
need to be done with our root crops but
in general plants that have a lot of
sinks that can adapt you if you can add
sings to take advantage of the extra
carbon those plants tend to respond much
better to long-term carbon dioxide
enrichment and that's one thing about
especially with apples the number of
apples are set early in the season and
during that time of the season when
they're really being set the final
numbers are being established that's the
time when the plant is under carpet next
so we've done some we've done some
shorter term studies with co2 enrichment
or even injection of sorbitol into the
trees and been able to cause a very
dramatic increase in the set of those
trees so we're expecting that Apple's
will respond prey quite well to be to
the extra carbon because the carbon is
limiting at the time they they set the
sinks and there's lots and lots of extra
sinks here's a commercial crop may only
be five to ten percent of the flowers so
we've got a lot of extra seat capacity
that you can add so so we think that
increase yields do then with you co2 may
be a very significant factor and the
increase just as I mentioned
380 is enough to really increase the
photosynthesis of the tree and from our
models would suggest that there should
have been subsequent some increases in
fruit set and yields just over the last
30 or 40 years due to that of course we
don't have a real experiment to prove it
so I think with these crops again our
heart ones that are likely to respond to
the climate in some ways and some
passive ways too so what about the
future what's going to happen I don't
want to go through all the minor change
information they've wolf cover a lot of
that and yard is going to to talk also
but for those in here Dave just a few
slides sort of the best at the stage
there have been several studies on the
report of the Northeast climate impact
assessments and they're available online
climate choice of dot org and so they've
done a lot of work days but contributor
to that and so it's climbing choice of
that org also if you're interested in
grapes nice article and the practical
winery magazine by K villain fields that
gives us to do in summary of that so
basically the climate models run they
have different scenarios and I don't
want to go into all those but basically
a lot of the compare
the show here we're done with the lower
emission scenario that's basically
saying that we actually wind up as a
society stop cranking all this extra co2
into the air and we level it out and
eventually bring it down then by the end
of the century so that's that's you know
we really behave well and then the
higher one red is if sort of businesses
usual keep keep going and so on this
there's been about we mentioned about
two degrees warming since 1970 just
until today last four years even with a
with a good lower emissions scenario
because of the inertia of something like
this massive is our oceans and climate
they still expect to see something
around a four to six degree a type of
increase so even at least doubling hope
you've already seen recently and of
course the higher scenario which i think
is almost being shown to be not as high
as it should be out is more the sixx 8
10 12 degrees universities a huge planet
but they're using these to serve a
bracket where we think would be the best
worst case scenarios how they use this
type of illustration this is from those
applications attention that are
basically saying the yellow on the left
is upstate New York right is the new
york city region if you look at upstate
from the historical climate
in our position there that by the end of
the century with the best case scenario
we're probably going to be more like
Virginia climate in terms of temperature
and then of course with the business as
usual high emissions scenario would be
more down into south carolina georgia
atlanta kind of kind of conditions and
in the 60 to 80 years and that sets with
them have some lifetimes here so it's a
sort of a scary scenario now persons
very greatly simplified because the
climate won't be exactly that way but
this just gives an idea of the type of
range when you start talking about those
changes and when if you look to see
clients that have those types of
climates see where you are this is also
some data about showing the in the
Alpine and red is the historic area for
snowfall snow covered during the winter
and then in the white shows again late
60 80 years from now the type of areas
that will have snow cover with with
their predictions and with the
temperature patterns you know the exact
implications of this a little bit hard
to say in some cases snowfall if snow
covers particularly helpful for
perennial plants to be able to
especially for some of the wine grapes
to be able to cover base of the plants
and we can't depend on it but if it does
cover the planet is a very good
insulator so it may help us survive them
those few really cold spells that we do
yet but it looks like we're not going to
be able to depend on that in the near
future so that's a pretty dramatic
change and again that's one of those
sort of tipping point things it doesn't
take too many degrees of change to go
from snow to rain and and change the
snow cover there's also been some just
saw today some ice on the Great Lakes
and even though it still varies a lot
the last in the 2000s there's been quite
a few years where there's very very
little ice formed and I can remember
seneca lake at the 70s and actually
freezing all the way down to dresden and
now probably the grad students here been
here several years probably have not
seen any ice and also there have been
really dramatic changes in the in the
lakes also and preserve their very large
bodies to change very much it mentioned
that be warmer but the most of these
spikes the cold spikes but hot spiced
and so New York
city is placed basically in the states
that they're very concerned about that
and so this plot that are provided shows
the number of days per year named plot
over 90 degrees and again on the Left
1961 the 90 long term and that the
different lower entire emission
scenarios showing commanding increases
of the numbers of days over 90 and then
the inset just shows that they're
expecting days over a hundred today to
go from a couple this per year to be
late the season with the high emission
scenario 225 almost a month 400 degree
temperatures in new york city that has
real major implications for for the city
and state and i just look back in this
summer in central park head 34 days over
90 degrees i think there were 17 days
july over 90 degrees nice and central
park starts
for payment either so thank you saw
their respective see extremes and also
obviously expands up to have in the
country as well how as I mentioned in
precipitation this is a plot showing the
types of variation this is something
that's a lot more difficult to predict
because of predicted clouds of rainfall
is a lot more lot harder but they did
some beverages basically they're showing
for this region it's not going to be a
dramatic change but be a grantor they
increase I think over that time they
look looks like it's maybe digging up
and that ten fifteen percent of those
type of increasing yields rainfall again
I think primarily spring and fall as we
get into the warmer winters less
snowfall then it turns into rain but
we're not going to be seeing a lot of
reduction in Game fall that's about a
beach intimate scene so that's that's
one of the good news but again they
they're predicting we haven't seen
greater heavy rainfalls and then maybe
drive your agenda choices okay so let's
talk about some of the likely impacts
talked about sound a little bit more and
project board future okay some of the
factors would be warmer winters where
the
so that more droughts heavy rain longer
growing seasons I our co2 in the air and
and likely with warmer winters more than
the disease pressures and weeds because
we won't be killing off during the
winter dispatch so let's look a few
examples and see what we might be
expecting many of them are extensions of
what we have seen but again it might be
two or three fold the effect we've been
looking at with the warmer winters
obviously maybe it would grow warmer
more tender varieties especially in the
wine grape area New York is becoming
very well-known wine producing area now
and the expansion there's a great future
for the industry and being able to have
a wider range of grapes that can be
grown here will be very positive for the
industry however in the shorter term we
may eventually get to the point where we
never got any real winter kill many
places but but in the shorter term we
may have this sort of up and down
situation will have a warmer winter but
because we may have warmer periods
during the winter the vitamin D
acclimate so and so even if its water we
may still get ways
jury because of the temperature so much
as because of the fact that we've had
deactivating periods and we've already
seen this this is just some plots from
Nelson excuse me Martin governing about
the blood acclamation for Kevin a
Riesling and Concord over a couple
different years he's showing the general
pattern and as you can see in the top
top part right here the same general
pattern of the other grapes these would
be the temperature pretty sure these are
lt50 or the temperatures which fifty
percent of the buds will kill and you
can see the top grab that as you go down
through the season there's some
differences in the in the varieties but
you notice they prepare Concord and
Cabernet Cabernet on top is quite a bit
slower to get to its maximum parties
because you followed out by
january-february they're really not as
different as you might expect but during
the early part of the season Cabernet is
more tender but yeah it's a little bit
hard to follow the lines but if you
follow them when they come out of this
the winter in the spring the Concord
comes out quickly the Cabernet is a
little bit slower so it shows that
there's some different patterns of
acclamation acclamation and deactivation
it could be quite important we need to
understand those because of we have
certain weather patterns
varieties the better suit or less
responsive to those warm periods that
may be may be quite helpful the bottom
plot just shows the temperatures were
going along and then they really drop
dramatically and they did a point where
the cabernets were killed but they had
really quili brated yet and so the other
conquerors recently able to survive oh
now we saw that this example in a couple
different years one that I mentioned was
2000 for the 2004 was the gin word part
of this plot and so in the dark blue you
can see the these are the daily minimum
temperatures and so they were advancing
along and november december so and in
1994 which was a year that we got almost
we were then a degree or two of the same
cold temperature at the very end but you
could see that in the period before the
coldest temperature the minimum
temperatures really never got above
freezing they were are always fairly
consistently cold and so the vines
didn't deactivate so when when they did
have the minus 13 or 14 there was by q
but it wasn't a major catastrophe for a
for the industry but in 2004 the blue
line you can see that created just
for the coldest temperature of these are
the minimums and a lot of those days
didn't even get decreasing so again
normally warm period for a significant
amount of time almost three weeks and
then it took about four day for five
days and it just went through the floor
and hit 90s 15 16 depending where you
were and would massive lion kill
tremendous impact on the industry so
again the temperatures that at the very
bottom were dramatically different but
it with the warming of that period
period before the cold that really got
to us 2004 so we're expecting that until
the climate warms up quite a bit more
that there may be some of these years in
between where where we might actually
see killing an even higher temperature
than we normally see just because of
these D acclimating periods so that's a
that's a concern for the industry
there's not really a lot you can do
about it we basically tend to wait until
as late as possible into the March April
to do the pruning so that you can that
you could remove canes and cut the buds
to look at see what percentage of them
are still alive and then you can adjust
the pruning but we typically up we do
that pretty much as a normal procedure
and also so that's something that
that think is like what they happen
before we get completely out of the
winter kill tackle climate of course if
you have my love winners and some of the
past diseases that are killed back by
our winners and grapes your such disease
for example there's a lot of other
diseases and pests that to the south of
us don't normally make it through the
winners here or likely to to make it it
will tend to increase our pesticide
loads probably because we're going to
have to deal with those additional but
the ones that we have now probably are
not going to go away because the winter
cell partner and then they actually may
be surviving the better so that's a real
concern about the warmer climate is is
the increased pesticide herbicide load
this is just a example showing kudzu we
always think of as a real southern type
of plant but with the the glutes are
basically main point through all the
details but it's the they relate to the
number of days below minus 20 Celsius
that these relays are live completely
kills that's it would basically the
point is that consume is going to be
able to move north if our climate
continues
so instead of grape vines growing all
over our journeys they might be fighting
with the kudzu in the future so that is
a real real concern now some of the
timing of the seasons we mentioned that
the grapes and things are the apples are
blooming earlier in general this is not
only the spark possible court or other
lancet spring generally would be
arriving in one to two weeks earlier
lower edition scenario three weeks
earlier by in 68 years from now that you
know that may be quite positive for
soccer growing season the growing season
is expected to extend longer because of
that one of the issues though is if we
start getting earlier but breaker we're
going to have more frost injury because
of that earlier but bring I show you
some data there and then of course we
expect that more summer we're getting
longer on both ends okay at this issue
of spring for us we went back and looked
over that same period of time that I
showed you the Apple data for Geneva and
we looked for the last 28 degree
Fahrenheit
to Celsius temperatures in the spring
because plant tissues don't freeze a
zero a couple degrees below zero two to
create super cooling of the site so we
we didn't fly the line of above is the
same regression I showed you from Apple
blue and then the progression down below
is for the last 28 degree frost and you
can see that that the those for us are
getting the last Ross is getting earlier
earlier and the in the year as well and
actually the rate of change is somewhat
faster than the greater change in the
Aqua play 11 days over 40 years versus a
grenade half days I think it was how so
so it doesn't necessarily look like
we're we're going to be expecting more
for us than average I think one of the
one of the difficult once predict is
many times the frost occur because of
clear skies and radiation for us well
try to predict radiation and the
cloudiness is something that's really
really difficult and so that that one is
a huge error bar and there
climatologists are saying when I don't
don't try to get anything too specific
that part but in general it doesn't it
doesn't look like frost you're staying
the same and our crops you're getting
over there you seem to be going along
pretty much the same okay so then if we
have warmer summers here's a study
saying okay for growing premium wine
grapes and this would be in the
relatively cool to mild to moderate
warmth growing season which is a fairly
threat of simplified way added but it
was a study done where they looked to
see what we're likely changes in plenty
of said suitable for that the type of
growing season and basically a lot of
detail as you move to the right you can
see that see on the upper left the areas
that are suitable the issue a live in
California Oregon Washington and even in
Arizona in that area Central Valley of
California it does have a lot of grapes
but they're just saying it's not it's
not optimal for premium quality cover
and chart a type of condition so but in
the future they're expecting
Californians who really have very
restricted areas that will be more of
the Napa Valley or Mendocino or some
type of conditions but in the upper
right hand corner you can see that there
really expecting the Northeast in one
area
is benefited the growing season now it's
a very simplified approach want to be
too much into it but it does it does
suggest that we may be a to benefit
where other other places are going to be
excessively now besides just looking at
the general trans and doing some
qualitative estimates worth going on we
did try to use our carbon balance models
that we've been developing one for grave
and apple and this is a simulation that
we did with my sim great model where we
looked at the simulated daily co2
fixation or do the other respiration /
mine and how with the heavy black line
the black lines you can see is the the
top the top lines are the photosynthesis
and the lower ones are the respiration
and the black line is is taking a
average of a current year it was a quite
average year and put together we pulled
some months out from different years
that that had an average average average
mean temperature but we wanted to keep
that variation I'm just using a flat me
too so that is sort of our
situation and then and then we added
five degrees Celsius to see what would
happen with a 5 degree warming the
average but we kept that same variation
and so you can see several things one is
obviously you as we got warmer we didn't
necessarily see any higher maximum
photosynthesis of the of the plants
because we're an hour Silver's pretty
close often but as it is where you did
see a difference is that because we had
a warmer growing season the trees get
started earlier and so you end up with a
longer growing season so the the red
line is shifted off to the right a later
part of growing season and so you can
pick up extra drag on a production there
but of course the warmer conditions lead
to more respiration and as you can see
how the red lines there are more days
that have really suboptimal
photosynthesis this would be the heat
spice expecting to see so we're using
the simulation models to try to look at
some of these and so this is just sort
of a summary and on the top join that
between those two seasons suggested that
there ended up to about a twenty percent
increase in total photosynthesis about a
thirty five percent increase in the
respiration and because of the
respiration flower so take the
difference we got about ten to twelve
percent or so increase in cumulative dry
matter by having that extra five degrees
so it's some positive effect based on a
dramatic effect how the so the summary
that would be
one more year reach those temperatures
for bud break about two weeks earlier
than normal and end up with a 45 week
longer season there will be some more
photosynthesis but because of the
introduced respiration the net effect
isn't is great the real real concerns
over possibly not averages but those
those spikes cause heat spice that may
be very detrimental to fruit quality and
they're seeing a lot of this place like
Australia where for the getting east
bikes and its really causing some
problems with quality not necessarily
you so overall there's probably a
positive there may be some episodes that
may be a concern ok so what about
situation with work or heavy rains and
it drops in between ok that suggests
that we probably the sites that will
have both excellent drainage and good
water supply well you know if you go to
a really well great site a lot of times
you're short of water and you have
cycles a lot of water a lot of heavy
rains you may be in trouble so we
definitely will need very good approach
control so we'll probably have to use
cover crops to to be able to stabilize
the soil and those will tend to use
water also in between times so maybe the
best sites especially for grapes will be
sites that will be there very highly
drained but be sure to have irrigation a
drip irrigation system with it and in
many ways that actually is a simulation
of some of the some of the very best
vineyards in the world to produce the
best quality extremely well dream but
then they actually naturally have deep
roots supply of water and so maybe we
have to basically use that approach okay
some of the other things though is it
with more Renick precipitation you also
get over formatted rainfall because if
you have droughts typically you've got
more sunny conditions as the earth dried
and when it's wet you've got a young
clouds to precipitation so penny crops
don't particularly respond that lunch
tuesday at three or four day period that
the heavy rain well grapes and apples
really can respond quite strongly to
short periods episodes and those sorts
of things here's an example just like a
heat spike where we can look back on our
own current data and this is the was
just showing in geneva the temperatures
this is right in that critical period
for example set and write the end of May
early June and we had a little bit
difficult see but they're actually about
five days above 80 or so and very warm
nights and sixties which other just that
time
45 day Pete's pay can cause significant
reduction in fruit set especially grower
is applying a chemical thinner right at
that time you can have some dramatic
loss of fruit I was in ordered white
recently and about a year ago they they
had a very heavy set of apples just
before they were going to fin that for
cloudy days to rain all that much group
was just for really cloudy days and they
have massive drop of fruit just a
tremendous drop and it caused not only
problems with the growers and not having
probably needed but also that all that
thinning was done by hand and so it
through a tremendous number of people
out of work so there are a lot of social
sociological issues that came up because
of that 14 day clouded period and the
growers didn't even notice it's not
something to think about monthly so
that's something that is when you get
more erratic weather more episodes this
could be a real issue for us and yet
climatic climate modelers say we can't
predict that type of things too
difficult so okay co2 of the air it's
used for photosynthesis so there should
be increased possibility for for dry
matter yield especially our crops that
can take advantage of that may help with
water use efficiency time to snow makes
clothes somewhat due to the co2
more photosynthesis beginning glass or
not much more increase in water loss so
what a sufficiency may be improved and
the effects on athlone quality wine
quality is really not very clear it was
one study with grapes and they found
more yield of a similar quality so they
didn't really see too much effect but
they didn't really go into a flamer boat
plans either so that's a big big
question mark for the grape side and
there has been work done Lou Siska has
done a lot of work where he had co2
engagement plus and he found that weeds
seemed to respond much better to co2 the
crops in case so they found that that
the weed weed pressure dramatically
increased with with high co2 and again
this is mainly to hire herbicide loads
and turns that way so what are some of
the things that we can try to do to
adapt to it adapting to this avoidable
change it's going to require a lot of
flexibility we some of the key issues or
we need to understand oh how soil
variability they interact with us with
the climate variability mentioned about
the water house and heavy rainfall need
to understand what to see
is likely to be and that really needs
long-term co2 enrichment studies which
are very expensive and become once they
were done with the primary grain crops
then came not fashionable anymore so
it's been there is one free air co2
enrichment project going on guys of time
Germany they'll have grapes and some
apples they believe in your also so
we'll be good to see that and then we
need to think more about and study a
little more about winter hardiness
responsibilities different wine
cultivars maybe maybe even if we could
grow some of that they may have a
response that's not exactly what we need
ok so the annotate we can shift to
better adapted varieties of course
that's that that's a fairly obvious won
the Breeders ultimately tell us that
while we can solve everything so well
you know we'll just breathe better
varieties but especially in the wine
grape area go on Kevin a they don't want
janila selection 43 as such so it's a
lot harder when when you have named
varieties to to change that genotypic
blend other other plans that people
don't care about variety can change much
more quickly so we need to be looking
also and maybe sites that are going to
limit the or reduce the effects of the
dead that components and then we may
need to try to again the correct
management since we're not changing
genotypes
do a lot of crop management with these
scrubs so here probably also good word
for Greg Jones's talk to give this plot
showing growing season temperatures and
where the different varieties seem to
fit the line the dash line on the left
is where Geneva is currently a finger
legs pretty much and you can see that it
goes pretty much right through Riesling
Pinot Noir and Chardonnay is pretty good
and we're a little bit a little bit cool
for cellulose and Beyond and kept
trancas right at the red the edge and
then as you go down there really not
very feasible to grossing with other
varieties now I put the second line to
the right to degree change and you can
see that that's a pretty significant
change in the potential varieties for
degree change is going to push even
further so these the level of change
that we're talking about is enough to
really really make us want to be looking
in the future that's not something we
have to do right away which is good we
have a little time but but it will be we
will have an opportunity to grow some of
the things that can't now however we may
be out the region that optimum before
the things that we do well recently
signature varieties burgundy is almost
getting too warm for his own signature
variety show so that's a
future the other thing is in any one
location if you have to paw grafite you
can you know not all sides of a hill
have the same environment so this is in
germany where they implanted very very
steep south-facing vineyard to to change
the sun angle so that it would be more
equivalent to like memos and burgundy
france and so this is one of our
approach they've actually been finding
that it has it's been getting too warm
so it's almost not optimum anymore so
one of the things that we may do is here
or on the cool side we're pushing things
on to better better exclosures maybe in
the future lighting you might be wanting
to go from the south side with these
varieties and recently bring it around
to the north side ski slopes are on
north-facing slopes for a good reason
and so we may be able to actually just
go around the hill and try to get away
from some of the subdiv warming language
so that may be one adaptation so and
then cultural practices we do a lot of
different things may be changing the
floor management has mentioned the
rainfall but also drought putting an
irrigation and gradually do a lot of
work
now if it's cool we're trying to remove
these to get the fruit in the Sun to
warm it up and more places they're
happily believes over top of fruit to
shade so we are manipulating the climate
within a plan so that gives us some
possibility of again manipulating and in
a way to counteract so don't get work a
little bit longer but just some some
closing thoughts on you know future
research things one is that we certainly
need to get a better understanding crop
responses to the environment there has
been a lot of work over the years but in
many cases have been the interactions
between the components of the
environment that we're seeing changing
and of course whenever you're trying to
look into the future you can't do that
with experiments very well so we have to
use models more to understand how the
plants work and then how they're likely
to respond to those changes so I think
models that have got the bad reputation
over the years I think we're going to
have to use them more and also
understand what their reputations are
but there's if you look to the future
there's not a lot of choices without
using models and then also there's
there's a lot more outside
be carbon carbon credits and things like
that that may be positive or negative
depending on carbon footprint but we
need to understand how those things will
impact your burgers as well it's just
the plants and then I think there's a
lot of new technologies out and new ways
of looking at things that that the
growers are having to be a lot more
aware of and issues of the consumer
consumer is looking for things there's a
lot more things about carbon reduction
labeling and those sorts of things so
these will have big impacts so oh I have
to thank you for your attention so bit
late but I'd be happy to answer any
questions question is do we have a table
for an apple brace similar to that oh
she's not well I haven't actually put it
together I guess serving an army had we
sort of know certain a Macintosh is a
very cool season apple variety doesn't
do well even in the lower hudson valley
so much and certainly not down south of
us so so we sort of had the concept but
i seen anyone actually
oh yes when Greg Jones was here he
talked about in grapes at least the bud
break was earlier but there was also a
compression of the stages so that the
more rapid development moving through
the different phenological stages and I
understood it right it wasn't actually
extending the season for ripening in the
grapes because the maturation went more
quickly at the high temperature you see
anything like that in Apple's where
instead of getting the longer season
that you predict as possible because of
bras three days just more rapid
maturation brings you know the apple
crop it needs to be harvested earlier
yeah actually it's the stages of
development tend tend to be all pushing
someone forward now will be I think
there's several several aspects with one
is that if you're in the spring so bud
break to bloom something like that that
tends to be driven by degree days
because they're fairly cool time of a
season so that will tend to be
compressed if you have a warmer warmer
period except by by moving earlier in
the season the you're always starting
about the same temperature because
that's when the tree census is the right
temperature began to grow so unless
unless you start earlier to have a more
rapid warm up the warm-up rate is the
same then you would you wouldn't expect
to see that that period shortened very
much and so I haven't seen a lot of
evidence
the period from Sabo draped bloom is is
going to get dramatically shorter that
tends to be tends to be more of a
maritime will be a longer period because
it's a slower warm-up and a continental
climate will tend to be a more magnet
one because it heats up very quickly but
for s I'd if I don't necessarily expect
to see the difference in that period to
be that much different at just
everything shifted forward how the
period from with Apple there tends to be
a model that was developed land deed
here in cornell found that the
temperatures after blown or a cell
division period tendus set the number of
days to harvest and so the middle of the
season the degree days don't always
Korando control growth very well because
a lot of times you're right it's sort of
a maximum of response and so a few
degree days when way or another doesn't
doesn't affect things too much so i
think generally we expect to see let
break earlier bloom earlier not
dramatically different harvest somewhat
earlier but I came from but great to
harness that hope going and we're seeing
very much change in that period except
everything is shifted forward in case of
apples but one of the limitations of our
climate for our fruit crops is the post
harvest period because some years we've
actually harvested fruit with snow onion
but there's almost no time at all for
the mines to recover or buttons or
apples to recover just to develop
additional
additional group growth after harvest so
i think i think that post harvest period
is where you're going to see the biggest
effect of the climate change and that's
a period that allows the Lions and the
trees to recover from the crop and it
seems to be able to help the crop set
more fruit the next year so I guess I'm
still not sure whether we're seeing that
type of compression with the types of
changes that we see is any evidence
called heat stress in lines or apples
that contains growth in the middle of
the season for me you get these days
above 90 or etc yes we have seen some
cases where we have seen actually sort
of bleaching of the leaves when we had a
very hot spell with our graves and the
photosynthesis rate was reduced by
fairly significant about twenty or
thirty percent and that tended to stay
there wasn't a recovery to that so
sometimes and I know in areas of Central
Valley of California you get real heat
spells that mine basically shuts down
and really doesn't really doesn't
produce very much and you get delayed
ripening because of that so yeah I think
there's there's a few studies that have
been looking trying to document that
little bit more but there have been a
lot of observations by growers over the
years that those heat spells not only
caused the problem right at that time
but they can cause problems in terms of
longer term problems of hurting the leaf
function so yeah there can be some clear
effects of this
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu